hey everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel today we will learn
about the top three cloud service
providers which are gcp Azure and AWS
that's said if these are the type of
videos you'd like to watch then hit that
like And subscribe buttons and the bell
icon to get notified just for a quick
info if you want to upskill yourself
master cloud computing skills and land
your dream job or grow in your career
then you must explore simply learns go
of various cloud computing programs
simply learn offers various
certification and postgraduate programs
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like
Caltech IIT guati AWS and many more
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work expertise in skills
like serverless Computing
containerization and orchestration VPC
design and implementation and over a
dozen others that's not all you also get
the opportunity to work on multiple
projects and learn from industry experts
working in Top Tire product companies
and academic from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into a cloud
computing role as a fresher or moved
onto a higher paying job profile if you
are passionate about making your career
in this field then make sure to check
out the link in the pin comment and
description box below to find a cloud
computing program that fits your
experience and areas of Interest Welcome
to the tutorial about Google Cloud
platform and here we will learn about
cloud computing what is cloud computing
what is
gcp that is your Google Cloud platform
what are the benefits of Google Cloud
platform and what are its different
Services a little bit about Google's
infrastructure a comparison of different
Cloud providers such as Google offering
gcp that is Google's Cloud platform
Amazon offering Amazon web services and
Microsoft which offers Azure we will
also learn about Domino's Piza use case
and then have a quick demo on using some
of the services on
gcp before we begin let's understand why
cloud computing and it would be always
good to learn about cloud computing
based on a use case there are varied use
cases where organizations are adopting
or moving their Solutions or their
infrastructure into cloud or I can
simply say integrating with Cloud now
here is one use case Nina started a
company that relates to website
development the challenges which Nina
was facing were low memory space
whenever required for processing or for
any other kind of application related
work high traffic to website that
crashed it and also less number of
servers now with these challenges she
was then referred to concept of cloud
computing and how that could benefit and
help her in solving her issues most of
her issues were solved when she started
using cloud computing and with cloud
computing she could increase her memory
space as required that is on demand
control the load to the website that is
basically load balancing and handling
more requests on the website or requests
per minute buying servers at a lower
price that is scaling up or down based
on the
requirement when we talk about cloud
computing cloud computing is use of
hardware and software components which a
cloud provider offers as a service which
can be accessed over over Network cloud
computing is use of these resources
which could be either dedicated
resources or coming from a pool of
resources which cloud provider offers to
deliver a service to clients users can
access these different Services
applications files from any device which
can basically access
Internet cloud computing allows
automatic software integration
it allows backing up and restoring of
data it basically offers unlimited
storage memory or computation
capacity it gives access to reliable
sources which usually the cloud provider
themselves are using for their use case
and it is a cost efficient model which
helps organizations to quickly integrate
or basically modernize their
infrastructure cloud computing is
usually used with it or within it space
wherein there are five traits if there
is a requirement of
resources as the business dynamically
changes or grows so for this cloud
computing offers on demand
self-service so users could be using on
demand Computing
resources or memory resources storage
Network and so on provided by cloud
provider and also do a
self-service all this is possible using
a simple interface and users can be
using processing power storage Network
as they need and pay as they go so there
is least or no human intervention
required when it comes to projects which
might need scalable network access cloud
computing offers broad network access
that is accessing resources over Network
across geographical regions or what we
call as availability zones which might
be multiple sites within a particular
geographical region Cloud providers also
have what we call as resource pooling so
this basically provides a huge pool of
resources which are shared and can be
accessed by customers at a lower cost
now there might be customers which are
interested in not sharing the resources
and would be interested in dedicated
resources and in this case cloud
provider also have so tenant offerings
which help such customers if an IT
business or any other business needs
rapid
elasticity then Cloud providers also
have resources which are offered which
are elastic you can get more resour
sources rapidly as needed and thus you
can scale up and down think of a gaming
company which would be interested in
launching a new game and they would have
predicted a certain number of users
which would get onto the portal playing
the game and what happens if the request
per minute or if the number of users who
are joining in might increase now in
this case organization would want an
underlying solution which handles this
dynamism scales as needed on demand and
once the demand is done scales down this
is possible using a cloud computing
solution cloud computing Solutions also
include measured services that is pay as
you go model for the usage or for the
reservations which a user or
organization would have made for
resources offered by cloud computing so
when we talk about cloud computing one
of the question which always arises is
why is this model so compelling why is
this so interesting for organizations or
users who would want to use one or many
services from cloud computing so first
wave of trend which brought storage
cloud computing was what we call is Colo
that is collocation it shops that have
been using or managing huge amount of
data from decades basically wanted to
build their infrastructures to handle
their business needs now instead of
building costlier data centers they
would rent space or share facilities and
this was being done by organizations
even in past thus they would free up the
capital for other use cases now this was
more of user configured manage and
maintained by them later organizations
started thinking of virtualization so
that was again user configured but
provider managed and maintained so
components of a virtualized data center
matched that of a physical Data Center
and organizations would have virtual
devices separately managed from
underlying devices then later came
container based architectures or
basically automated services so within
Google services are automatically
provisioned
and configured letting your
infrastructure scale on demand there are
various reasons why an organization
would think of integrating with cloud or
benefiting by using cloud and thus
instantaneously reaping the benefits of
modernizing their
infrastructure now few famous Cloud
providers are here so you have Amazon
which offers Amazon web services and a
huge list of services which come in with
this you have Microsoft's Azure you have
oracles Cloud you have Sap's Cloud
Solutions gcp which is offered by Google
Salesforce and so on there are many
other small players which are also
providing different Services which are
cloud-based or organizations which are
partnering with these main Cloud
providers thus offering cloud services
to their
customers
when we talk about why Google Cloud
platform there are various reasons why
someone would choose Google Cloud
platform gcp has better pricing compared
to its
competitors when it comes to Speed and
Performance it is very fast and
increases the performance of the
project live migration of apps and there
are huge number of solutions which I
will show you further in further screens
which help an organization to adopt to a
cloud platform or integrate with Cloud
platform or even completely migrate into
a cloud platform none of Google's
competitors provide live migration of
apps when we talk about Big Data AI
machine learning kind of solutions gcp
provides a lot of innovative solutions
in comparison to other Cloud providers
such as AWS Azure and so
on
so what is Google Cloud platform it is a
set of Cloud Computing Services provided
by Google that runs on the same
infrastructure that Google uses to and
for its end user products like YouTube
Gmail and so
on let's learn about benefits of Google
Cloud
platform such as high productivity
working from anywhere quick
collaboration high security fewer data
stored on vulnerable devices reliable
resources which can be used across
organization across geographical regions
across
countries very flexible which allows
organizations to scale up and down as
the demand Rises or as the demand
declines and coste effective solutions
for various use cases these are some of
the benefits and if we look into
different services which Google Cloud
platform offers we could look into
detailed benefits which each service
offers in a different use case which
basically helps organizations working in
different domains handling different
kind of small mid or larger businesses
and with different business
goals when we talk about Google Cloud
platform Services here is a list of
services or I could say high level
domains or categories of services so you
have compute related Services you have
storage and database you have networking
Big Data developer tools identity and
Security Management Internet of Things
Cloud AI management tools and also data
transfer
Solutions when we talk about Google's
infrastructure Google has one of the
most powerful infrastructure in the
world the infrastructure is available in
two levels the physical and the abstract
layers you have physical infrastructure
and then you have the abstract
infrastructure physical infrastructure
consists of data centers extensive
development of high efficiency backend
data
centers you have a very strong backbone
Network which is used by Google itself
and also offered as services to
customers via gcp platform services so
you have Global mesed redundant backbone
Network points of presence when we talk
about Google it has 110 plus Edge points
of presence in more than 200 countries
and when we talk about Edge caching Edge
caching platform at periphery of their
Network so this is what defines the
physical infrastructure of Google now
there is much more to it rather than
just these four points when we talk
about abstract infrastructure that is
divided in global regions and zones when
we talk about Zone a zone is roughly
equivalent to a Data Center and a single
point of failure so you could have your
compute engine which is within a zone or
you could say compute engine is a zonal
resource you have regions which are
geographical areas which contain
multiple zones so so you could have a
region for us Central or Europe Central
Europe West and so on and within a
region you would have one or multiple
zones and zones basically would allow
High availability of
resources so you have Cloud load
balancer as an example which is regional
resource then you have global resources
and they are available and shared across
the planet so you have VAR global
resources such as Network which could be
even your IP addresses and so
on now let's do a quick comparison of
AWS WS Azure ws gcp and let's look at
what each cloud provider offers later we
will also look into different services
in detail when it comes to Google Cloud
platform what each service does what you
can benefit from which service should
you use in what case we will learn about
those in later slides if I compare your
different Cloud
providers when we talk about Amazon and
its Cloud offerings that is Amazon web
services or AWS as we well know it
Amazon web services has 69 availability
zones within 22 geographical locations
and soon it will have 12 more in future
so this number keeps growing based on
the spread of the services which a
particular cloud provider offers here we
are talking about availability Zone
specific information when we talk about
Microsoft's Azure it has 54 regions
worldwide and is available in 140
countries across the globe when we talk
about Google Cloud Google Cloud platform
is available in 200 plus countries
across the
globe when we talk about virtual servers
Amazon's ec2 that is elastic compute
Cloud it is a web service which
basically helps to resize your compute
capacity where you can run your
application programs on a virtual
machine so using ec2 service you could
launch virtual instances that could have
any distribution of Linux Windows you
could have different specifications when
it comes to Ram or CPU course or disk
you could also decide on what kind of
storage a particular instance should use
whether the storage should be local to
the instance or whe whether that should
be a elastic file system or even an
object storage when it comes to Azure or
Microsoft's offering as your virtual
machine that is infrastructure as a
service gives a user the ability to
deploy and manage a virtual environment
inside a virtual Network on the cloud
and and this virtual Network on the
cloud would be managed by cloud provider
Google cloud or the offerings from
Google Cloud platform that is gcp VM
instances enables users to build deploy
and manage virtual machines in order to
run different kind of workloads on the
cloud now when we talk about compute
engine here it would be good to discuss
a little bit more about compute engine
and what are the different options which
Google Cloud offers so when you talk
about your compute engine you have
scalable high performance virtual
machines computer engine delivers
configurable virtual machines which run
in Google's data center with access to
high performance networking
infrastructure and block storage and you
could select VMS for your needs that
could be general purpose or workload
optimized and when we talk about
workload optimized you have pre defined
machines or you have custom machine
sizes you can integrate compute with
other Google cloud services such as AI
or ML and go for your data analytics you
have when we talk about your gcp VM
instances just to expand on that you
have general purpose instances which we
call as
N2 which provide a balance between price
and performance and they are well suited
for most workloads including lineup of
business applications web servers and
databases Google Cloud also offers
compute optimized instances which we
call as C2 instances which offer
consistent high-end virtual CPU
performance which are good for AAA
gaming Eda HBC and other applications
now when we talk about compute optimize
or general purpose how would we leave
memory optimized instances those are M2
machines which Google offers so these
offer highest amount of memory these VMS
are well suited for inmemory databases
such as sap Hana realtime analytics and
inmemory caches so if I would summarize
this when we talk about different
instances
AWS also offers different kind of
instances which are memory or compute or
disk optimized you have generally
purpose and each category of machines
has a different pricing model you can
always go to an AWS website look for the
pricing models and that will give you an
idea of on demand instances or dedicated
instances reserved instances and so on
similarly if you talk about Google Cloud
Google Cloud also has instances with
various options which become the key
features of why customers would choose
Google Cloud platform such as as live
migration for VMS so computer engine
within your gcp can live migrate between
host systems and when I say live migrate
it basically means without rebooting
which keeps your application running
even when the underlying host systems
require maintenance you also have
preemptible virtual machines wherein you
can run bad jobs and fault tolerant
workloads on preemptible VMS to reduce
your vir ual CPU and memory cost by up
to 80% while getting the same
performance so these are your preemptive
or preemptible virtual machines the only
dmit is these can give you a really cost
efficient resource usage however can be
taken off the shelf anytime and that's
why we call them preemptible virtual
machines you also have soul tenant notes
which are physical compute engine
servers dedicated explicitly or
exclusively for users use case and when
we talk about Soul tenant nodes these
are usually good when you are dealing
with or when you're working with your
applications which we call as bring your
own license applications so Soul tenant
nodes give you access to same machine
types and virtual machine config options
as regular compute instances so there
are different options which Google Cloud
offers when it comes to the
instances which we are talking about and
it takes care of different use cases in
comparison to other Cloud providers
which are also offering these services
such as you can have predefined machine
types you can have customer machine
types preemptible VMS as I said live
migration of VMS you can use persistent
diss which could give you durable high
performance block storage you have local
ssds you also have GPU accelerators
which can be added to accelerate
computational intensive workloads such
as machine learning simulation medical
analysis and so on and you have features
such as Global load balancing which
makes Google Cloud a unique
Choice when we talk about platform as a
service Amazon has platform as a service
offering which we call as elastic bean
stock among one of its services it's an
orchestration service for deploying
applications and helping in maintaining
these applications Azure cloud service
provides a platform to write the user
application code without worrying about
the hardware resources Google app engine
is a service used by Developers for
building and hosting applications on
Google's data centers when we talk about
serverless Computing so Amazon's AWS
Lambda is a a serverless compute service
it is used to execute backend code and
scales automatically when required when
we talk about aure you have something
called as functions which allow users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with a programming
language of their choice when we talk
about Google cloud gcp has Cloud
functions which is easiest way to run
your code in the cloud and it is highly
available and fall tolerant so in these
days when we are talking about
microservices architecture which
organizations are preferring when we are
talking about organizations which can
scale which can dynamically change their
underlying architecture organizations
would be interested in serverless
Computing where they do not have to have
a infrastructure set up a planned in
advance before going for their use case
and this is where monolithic
applications are really not a Preferred
Choice lot of organizations are
decomposing their applications into
microservices based on business
capability or decomposing based on
subdomains we can learn about
microservices architecture later but
just to know that serverless Computing
which basically helps any organization
if for example if you have a web
application that receives non linear
traffic and you cannot keep an eye on
your server always it would be good to
have someone to autoscale your
application serverless is basically a
Computing model where cloud service
provider is responsible for managing the
piece of code without the developer
having to bother about infrastructure
setup management maintenance and so on
now when we talk about applications
being serverless or Ben benefiting from
serverless Computing one of the key
things would be zero Administration so
deploying application without any
provisioning and management autoscaling
capability that is let the service
provider worry about scaling the
application up and down you have paper
use model which any customer would want
to benefit from that is pay only for the
resources that you have used or that you
are continuing to use right short the
time between idea implementation and
employment and this is something which
any organization would want that you
would want a faster bring to the market
solution timeline in comparison to
getting entangled with deployment
management and maintenance of your
underlying infrastructure when your
applications are facing a high demand so
when we talk about serverless it is a
function as a service because each part
of your application is divided as
functions and can be hosted over
multiple service providers you have
serverless apps which are usually
divided as separate units or functions
based on functionalities or domains and
so on so serverless Computing is getting
quite popularity these days in
comparison to the traditional three tier
architecture where you had a
presentation layer you had an
application layer you had a database
layer now that kind of infrastructure is
not really preferred in today's modern
times when organizations are working on
different kind of newer
applications when we talk about object
storage Amazon has simple storage
service that is S3 it provides object
storage which is built for storing and
recovering information or data from
anywhere over the Internet aure comes up
with blob storage that is binary large
objects storage offers large amount of
storage and scalability it stores the
object in the tiers and depending on how
often the data is being accessed now
same thing applies to even S3 which is
from Amazon so S3 also has different
kind of storage classes which can be
selected when a user or a organization
intends to use a storage service and
when I speak about storage classes it
basically means having a frequent access
storage or a infrequent access storage
or what we call as just an archival
solution Google cloud has cloud storage
and it provides unified object storage
for live or archive data this service is
used to store and access data on gcp
infrastructure when it comes to
advantages Amazon web services has
Enterprise friendly Services easy access
to resources increase in Speed and
Agility and that to on demand and takes
care of your security and reliability of
resources which are offered when it
comes to Sor it has better development
operations strong security profile
provides lot of cost-effective solutions
and operation execution friendly when we
talk about Google Cloud one of the key
features here is better pricing than
competitors live migration of virtual
machines which really interests lot of
organizations would want to modernize
their infrastructure without having any
kind of disruption in their existing
Services improved performance redundant
backups and so on when it comes to
disadvantages in AWS you have
limitations when it comes to ec2 service
well there are different options in the
kind of machines which you can choose
which you can work on you have a
technical support fee which is incurred
network connectivity and then also
downtime which might be in case when
you're migrating asure it has different
codebase for cloud and premise platform
as a service ecosystem is not really as
efficient as infrastructure as a service
poor management of GUI and tools
integrated backup when we talk about
Google Cloud support fee is quite heavy
it depends on what kind of solution or
support you would or organization would
be interested in it has a complex
pricing schema although it has different
use cases for which any user or any
organization can benefit from
downloading data from Google cloud
services is an expensive option storage
might not be however uploading data or
downloading data would be an expensive
option
when we talk about Domino's Pizza use
case now while we were discussing about
these features I would really want to
spend more time in discussing each of
these features or services in detail
such as you have compute engine you have
storage you have big table you have data
proc and so on so there are huge list of
services now before we get into your
Domino's Piza use case let me show you
the space on Google Cloud where you can
look at different services so if you go
to cloud.google.com and if you look at
get started option under doc so here you
can find build Solutions look at
different use cases learn from basics of
what is your Google Cloud what are Cloud
Basics then you can look at different
Cloud products so here you have products
in different categories such as Ai and
machine learning
API management compute containers data
analytics databases developer tools and
so on and you can always click on any
one of these to look into different
solutions which are being offered what
are the different use cases what are the
best practices when it comes to
migrating VMS to compute engine or
operating containers or building
containers and so on you can always look
at featured products and that gives you
a quick snapshot of what are the
different products s such as you have
compute engine you have Cloud run big
query which is a data warehouse you have
Cloud SQL which is a managed biq
postgress you have cloud storage to
basically push in any kind of data there
you have security key enforcement Ai and
machine learning and so on so you have
different feature products now if you
scroll down to the lower end of this
page you can again look at different
solutions and that would be really
interesting to read and learn from so
you have infrastructure modernization
you have application modernization you
have data management and so on so if I
look at infrastructure
modernization you could basically look
at the solutions which Google Cloud
offers and what it does when it comes to
having your infrastructure modernized or
benefiting by integrating with cloud and
having immediate benefits of
infrastructure modernization you can
look at different use cases what they
are doing how Google Cloud really helps
when it comes to migrating the workloads
to a cloud and how your different Cloud
Solutions such as VM migration you have
sap on Google Cloud VMware as a service
and so on and you could learn from these
different solutions which are offered
you can also look at application
modernization so not only infrastructure
modernization but organizations would
also be interested in relooking at their
applications relooking at how these
applications could be moved from
monolithic to microservices architecture
or how applications can benefit from
modernization and cloud computing
offerings so you have again different
use cases here H which talks about
different ways in which Google Cloud can
help how you can modernize your
applications how you can use different
solutions which Google cloud is offering
now when we talk about Cloud Computing
Services you can always go into
cloud.google.com
if you have created a free account then
you can just login and every user by
default gets a $300 free credit so
wherein they can try out different
products where they can use different
services so here if I click on Console
where I'm already logged in with my my
Gmail account or my Google Cloud account
wherein I have $300 free credit out of
which some is being used you have a
Google Cloud console and here from the
hamburger menu you can click and you can
look at different services within
different domains so you have compute
domain which has different services such
as app you have compute engine and that
basically allows you to use your VM
instances which we were talking about
previous slides
different instance groups create your
templates use Soul tenant notes create
snapshots or backup of your data use
different zones you can go for
kubernetes which is containerized based
engine you have Cloud functions you have
Cloud run and then you have storage
related different options such as big
table you have data store fire store
file store storage and so on and for
each of these Services you can read
about from the Google documentation or
anyways I will be explaining that later
you can also look at networking related
operation related and other tools which
are offered by Google Cloud so these are
huge list of services which Google Cloud
platform offers in different ways for
different use cases now let's look at
this Domino's Piza use case and see what
it helps us learn about so you can
always access this page by going to this
link which talks about customers and
then which shows you different use
cases so Domino's increasing monthly
Revenue by 6% with Google analytics
premium Google tag manager and Google
big query so this is basically when
dominoes started using gcp and what was
the result of that now let's look
further into
this so we we all know that Domino is
most popular Piza delivery chain
operating across the globe but how was
that possible let's take a look so the
challenges were they wanted to integrate
marketing measurement across various
devices connecting CRM and Digital Data
to create a clear view of customer
Behavior to make cross Channel marketing
performance analysis easy and efficient
now for these challenges which Domino's
was facing the solution was using Google
analytics premium Google tag manager and
big query which were used to integrate
Digital Data sources and CRM data
reporting was made easier and more
efficient by implementing Google
analytics premium because it had the
ability to access a single Google
analytics account to evaluate web and
app
performance by using the new Google tag
manager implementation Dominos were able
to act fast they were able to connect
CRM data with digital analytics which
basically provided Domino with greater
visibility on customer Behavior what was
the result there was an immediate 6%
increase in monthly Revenue 80% of costs
in ad serving and operations were saved
increases agility with streamline tag
management the obtained easy access to
powerful reporting and customized
dashboards now that was just one simple
use case before we go on to handson we
can also talk a little bit back about
the services which Google Cloud offers
as we discussed and some of these
Services which can really make you think
why not Google Cloud platform so when we
talk about your different Cloud platform
services let's learn about some of these
services in brief in what each service
is what it does and how it can help us
in handling our use cases or working
with different products so let's learn
briefly about different Services which
Google Cloud platform offers now one of
the domains is compute and then let's
look at the compute Services which gcp
offers now here I can log into the
console and this hamburger menu on the
top left corner I can click on this one
and go into the compute engine section
so this is the compute domain which has
app engine kubernetes engine Cloud F
functions and Cloud run so these are
your different Services which are
offered within the compute domain and
here we can get into compute engine by
clicking on this one and then basically
going to VM instances so before we see
how we can use this compute engine let's
understand about about some of the
features of compute engine which
basically offer scalable high
performance virtual machines which are
configurable and which runs in Google's
data center with access to high
performance networking infrastructure
and block storage so from here you can
select VM for your needs for your
general purpose or workload optimized
predefined or custom machines now here
you can integrate compute with other
Google cloud services such as AI ML and
other data analytics Services you have
different machines which are offered
here such as general purpose which
provide a balance between price and
performance which are well suited for
most workloads including line of
business applications web services and
databases you also have compute
optimized machines which offer
consistent high-end virtual CPU core
performance and which are mainly good
for G gaming Eda High process Computing
and other such applications apart from
general purpose compute optimized you
also have memory optimized machines
which offer highest amount of memory and
these VMS are basically well suited for
in-memory databases such as sap Hana
realtime analytics and inmemory cache
now we can see these options here you
can click on VM instances while you're
logged in into your Google Cloud console
so here you can even create an instance
template which can be used to spin up
instances for example if I click on new
VM instance from a template there are
some templates which I have already
created for my usage now here I can
basically use one of these templates or
what I can do is I can go back I can go
into instance templates and this
basically allows me to create a template
so you can click on create instance
template which basically allows you to
create templates which can be used to
spin up different instances we can give
a name to the template for example we
can say template instance now here I can
choose machine configurations and this
is where you have different options so
you have general purpose as I mentioned
which provide a balance between price
and performance you have memory
optimized which are large memory machine
types for memory intensive workloads you
also have compute optimized which
basically give you high performance
machine types for compute intensive
workloads so you can choose any machine
configuration which is available here
based on your requirements now if you
click on general purpose that has
different options here so you look into
the series where you have N1 series you
have E2 which are CPU platform selection
based on availability you have N2 and
n2d so let's just have N1 selected now
you also have here which talks about
machine types and here we can choose the
configuration which we are interested in
depending on the applications which will
run within the machines we can choose a
machine so by default it shows one
virtual CPU core and 3.5 GB of memory or
Ram you could choose a higher end
machine so as of now I'll just say N1
standard now that basically allows me to
choose these machines so there are
different features which your computer
offers such as you have live migration
for VMS you have preemptable virtual
machines you have sold tenant nodes and
all those options can be seen here now
in this machine for my boot dis I can
select a distribution which I would be
interested in for example I could be
going for public images and I can choose
for example Ubuntu and then I can choose
a version so it shows me
16.04 and you also have latest versions
such as ubben 220 you can choose one of
these and here it asks you to choose the
boot disk type so that could be standard
persistent disk which is hdds which are
low in performance and uh you can say
low in cost in comparison to ssds so
ssds give you better performance but
then they are little expensive than
using standard persistent dis we can
choose this and we can give a disk size
for example 20 GB and I can click on
select before clicking on SEL select I
can click on custom images and that
shows me if you have any other images
created in your project you could use
those you could also learn about images
by clicking on this link so we'll click
on public images we have chosen this
distribution let's do a select and now
here you have identity and API access
management so let this be default you
can say allow default access and what
you need is depending on the services we
can choose it allows http p and https
traffic now we would also need some way
to connect to these machines so when you
set up an instance by default you can do
SSH into it using the Google Cloud
console or from cloud shell you can also
give a private and a public key so here
you have the option where you can give
all these details so when it comes to
management it tells you would would you
want to go for reservations and you can
say automatically use created
reservation you could also say no you
would not want to use a reservation you
can also set up or provide a startup
script which you would want to give
whenever your machines come up and here
you have the options of preempt ability
so compute offers preemptable virtual
machines so that is mainly when you
would want to run bad jobs and fault
tolerant workloads on these machines and
you can benefit with a reduced cost for
your virtual CPU and memory by
80% so these are virtual machines which
would be lasting less than 24 hours now
by default this is off and it purely
depends on your workload what you would
want to run on these instances I could
just go ahead and select preemptible
being on that and use this feature of
compute you also have on host
maintenance which talks about what would
be happening with this compute engine
instance so when compute engine performs
periodic infrastructure maintenance it
can migrate your VM instances to other
hardware and this is one of the features
which compute engine offers which we
call as live migration for VMS here your
computer engine can live migrate between
host systems that is the underlying
systems on which these VM instances are
based on without rebooting which will
keep your application running even when
host system require maintenance and here
it says migrate VM instense recommended
and let that be as it is you can also
say that if there is a maintenance
happening you can terminate the VM
instance now it also talks about
automatic restart which is on which
basically means computer engine can
automatically restart VM instances if
they are terminated from nonuser
initiated reasons so these are all the
settings which are available in
management and it also tells us the
different features which we have there
is also a feature called sold tency
which basically means sold tenant sold
tenant nodes which can be chosen so you
can have physical compute engine servers
dedicated exclusively for your use and
this is usually good when you're talking
about bring your own license
applications so Soul tenant nodes give
you access to same machine types and VM
configuration options as regular compute
instances however these might be a
little expensive we can choose this one
we can also look into networking which
basically shows the default setup which
goes for Auto subnet you can also choose
a particular IP if that is required but
that would cost more you can click on
discs which talk about what do you want
to do with the boot dis when the
instance is deleted what is the
encryption mechanism you would want to
use and here finally you have security
so basically as I said you can SSH into
instance using the cloud console option
and you can also provide a public SSH
key so one way of doing that that if you
intend to use an external SSH client
such as puty to connect you can create a
key so for example I can go into puty
gen and here I can say generate just
move my cursor over here and that will
create a key I can give a name to this
one so I'll say sdu will be username
I'll give a simple password which I will
use to login to this machine and then I
can save this private key which will get
saved so let's say hdu new key and this
gets saved in a PPK file which is
usually used when you use an external
SSH client to connect so save this one
and that saves a PPK file on your
desktop what you can also do is you can
copy this public key content from here
and this is what we would want to give
in our instance here so so that the
public key gets stored on the instance
and private key is what we will use to
connect so once I paste it here it
resolves the name to hdu and we have
given the public key now in certain
cases you may want to use a software
which uses SSH to connect to the machine
and that software might not be such as
your puty so in that case you may want a
pem file or a private key which is saved
as a pem file so you can also do that by
going to conversions and do a export op
SSH key and then save it so I'll say hdu
new key but then this one will be saved
as a pem file on my machine so you have
PPK file which allows you to use puty to
connect to the instance you have a pem
in case a software needs directly SSH to
these machines you also have the public
key which we have already provided in
the machine now once this is done I can
close puty gen I can go back to this
page where I'm creating an instance
template and then I can just click on
create so this has created a instance
template which I can use to spin up my
instances any number of instances using
the same template only thing which I
would have to do is change the region
where I would want the instance to run
so now that we have created instance and
that's my this one the third option I
can go back to VM instances now I can
click on Create and here I can either
create an instance from scratch by
giving all the details again or I can
just use my template so I can click on
new VM instance from a template choose
my template click on continue and once
this is done I can give my instance name
so let's say C1 I can choose the region
so I will choose Frankfurt and then rest
everything is autop populated based on
the template what you have given and you
click on create now this basically
allows you to spin up an instance and
you can create any number of instances
using your template you could have
already created a new instance right
from scratch now once the instance is
created this has a public IP and a
private IP private IP will not change
unless you would want to set up a new
machine but public IP will change every
time you stop and start the machine now
this is what we need to connect to this
machine I can also do a SSH from here by
doing this in open in a browser window
let's click on this so this is an
internal way of connecting to your
instance using SSH let's wait because it
would be transferring the SSH keys to
the VM it establishes a connection and
I'm connected to my machine what we can
easily do is to confirm if we are in the
right machine we can just do a LS to
look at the file system what we can also
do is we can basically log in as root by
doing a Pudo Su and that allows you to
get into the machine as root and from
here I can switch to hdu user which will
have a SSH directory in home and that
basically has authorized keys and if we
would want to see if this one contains
my public key I can just do a cat. SSH
and then look into authorize keys and
this shows me the public key which we
had initially added to our instance so
this confirms that we are logged into
the machine which we created now I can
close this and what I can also do is I
can copy copy this public IP so let's do
a copy to
clickbuy and here I will say host name
where I'll say hdu give my public key
I'll click on SSH and in SSH I'll go to
authentication now here we need to give
our PPK file so the PPK file was sdu new
key select this one come back here come
to the session give it a name for
example C1 save it and then you can just
say open and say yes and you are logged
in to your machine now once you're
logged in you can always do a minus SSH
and that shows you the file so this is
how you have just used the compute
engine to spin up an instance but we
used a template which basically allowed
me to create this instance and then I
can connect to this instance and then I
can start working on this so when we
talk about features of compute engine it
has predefined machine types as we s so
computer engine offers different
predefined virtual machines and this
they have configurations for every need
from small general purpose instances to
large memory optimized instances with up
to 11.5 tab of ram you can have fast
compute instances optimized up to 60
virtual CPU cores you also have custom
machine types so you can create a VM
that best fits your workload and by
tailoring a custom machine type to your
specific need you can realize
significant savings there are
preemptable VMS which we saw there is
also a facility which allows you to take
the benefit of live migration for VMS
you have durable high performance block
storage for virtual machine instances in
the form of persistent diss where data
is stored redundantly for integrity
flexibility and to resize storage
without interruption and you could be
choosing sdds or sdds for for your
instances now you also have option such
as GPU accelerators so for example if I
just click on create instance and I can
look into that so here let the instance
name be instance one and what I would be
interested in looking at this one which
says CPU platform and GPU so CPU
platform configuration is permanent you
can also do add GPU so gpus can be added
to accelerate computationally intensive
workloads like machine learning
simulation medical analysis and virtual
workstation applications so you can add
and remove gpus to a VM when your
workload changes and pay for GPU only
while using so these are some of the
features which basically compute engine
offers and we already know that Google
builds in second level increments so we
only pay for the compute time now there
are different savings which are possible
so you have Commit M savings which
basically means you can save up to 57%
with upfront cost per instance type
lockin you have container support so you
can basically run manage and orchestrate
Docker containers or compute engine
instances so here when we are setting up
our instances there is an option which
basically allows you to use or deploy
Docker images now that can be done you
can also benefit from sustained use
savings that is sustained use discounts
which are automatic discounts for
running compute engine resources for
significant portion of the billing month
you can create a reservation for VM
instance in a specific Zone which is
basically seen under your management
section here and you can ensure your
project has resources for future
increases in demand and if no longer
needed delete the reservation so these
are some of the features of compute
engine what we have done is we have
created compute engine using the console
now you can go back you can also do that
using Cloud shell and you can click on
this one which activates Cloud shell you
could also have the cloud SDK support on
set up on your machine which can be used
now I can just open this in a new window
and from here I can start giving
commands if I would be interested in
setting up an instance from my command
line so here you you have different
options now to begin with you can just
do a gcloud and just hit enter and that
will show you different options which
are available which can be used so you
have gcloud compute here which shows an
option to create and manipulate compute
engine resources now I can just do a q
to quit I can do gcloud compute and that
basically will again show me different
options which are available if you would
be interested in setting up instances
from the command line so here I can say
gcloud compute and then go for instances
and if you do not know the commands you
can just hit enter that will show you
all the different options which we have
so here we have different options such
as list or create or start or update for
example I can just do a list here to see
what instances I have and the instance
which we just created shows up here it
says that status is running I can just
stop this instance I can delete this
instance I can even create an instance
by using a create command here and you
can just do a create help which will
show you what are the different options
you can give so it says instance name is
what you need you can choose an
accelerator you can choose the boot dis
and various other options so I can just
say create and then I can give a name
for example C2 and once I click on this
one it says did you mean Europe West
four zone so it is asking me for the
region and the zone and I can say yes
and these settings are coming from my
default profile I can always change
those by changing the metadata so now we
have created an instance it says running
if we do a list again to see we see two
instances created one was in Europe West
3 one was in Europe West West 4 both of
them have internal and external IPS now
you can do a describe to look at the
different options here so gcloud
basically allows you different commands
which you can use to work with your
instance to create instances to change
the metadata if you would want to change
the region if you would want to add a
startup script all those options are
possible from the command line which we
can learn in detail in later sessions so
this is your computer compute engine as
a service now that we have learned about
the compute domain and G compute
Services which is offered by gcp let's
also learn about storage and databases
that's again within the storage domain
and the services which are offered by
Google Cloud platform now you can go
back to console and here you can click
on this one and here you can just scroll
down to see what are the different
options in storage so you have options
such as big table you have data store
fire store file store you have SQL Based
Services you have storage which is
object storage and then you have other
options which are available so Google
Cloud platform offers different storage
Based Services out of which storage
which is your object storage is quite
popular one click on storage and that
basically shows you an option which
talks about storage browser so this is
your Google Cloud's object storage so
when we talk about object storage it is
basically a storage where you could
store any kind of data and when we talk
about object storage it is a bunch of
bytes which we address wherein every
object will have a unique key these
unique keys are in the form of URL which
allows you to access the object so cloud
storage is comprised of what we call as
buckets which are used toore store and
hold your storage objects the storage
objects are immutable and every change
creates a new version now you can also
have control access via Imam that is
identity access management or via Access
Control list so there is also an option
called object versioning which basically
says if it is on every time you try to
store the same object a new version of
the object would be created otherwise
newer option will override old one as we
cannot archive the old version so let's
see how we work with this object storage
so here you can click on create bucket
now once you click on create bucket it
needs a name so let's say test bucket
and here I can just give say number one
so that says this is the name of my
bucket now I can directly click on
continue or it would be good to look at
different options which are available
here so when you click on choose where
to store your data so it already gives
me an option it says the bucket name is
already taken so let me give it a unique
name so let's say test buck and let's
call it AUA so that should be unique now
here it says choose where to store your
data so this one gives you location type
so you can have region specific buckets
which give you lowest latency that is
fastest response time within a single
region however it does not make your
storage highly available you can make a
dual region which is basically allowing
your bucket or storage to be accessible
across regions you can also make it
multi- region which is highest
availability offered as of now we can
choose region specific and now it asks
you to choose a location now as always I
will choose Frankfurt now I can click on
continue and all the rest let all the
storage options be default or you can
click on a default storage class now
that tells you based on your storage
class there are variant costs when it
comes to storing retrieving or doing any
kind of operations so you have a
standard option which says best for
short-term storage and frequently Access
Data you can also go for Cold Storage
such as near line which is best for
backups and data access less than once a
month you can go for free freeing
storage such as cold line best for
disaster recovery and data access less
than once a quarter or you can go for
archiving where the data is accessed
less than once a year let's go for
standard as of now and now you can
choose how to control access to objects
so you have fine grained or uniform let
it be fine grained wherein you can give
additional permissions at Bucket Level
using IM am or object level permissions
using access control list
in advanced settings you can choose the
encryption and you can also choose a
retention policy so a retention policy
to specify the minimum duration that
this buckets objects must be protected
from deletion or modification after they
are uploaded you can always learn about
this more by clicking here now once I've
chosen all the relevant options I can
click on Create and that basically will
create a bucket by the name I have given
I I can click on overview to basically
see brief details about my bucket such
as region what is the default storage
class and it also shows you the link URL
which can be used to access your bucket
it also gives you the link for GS util
now GS util is a command which can be
used in your Cloud shell to basically
work with your buckets you can click on
permissions to basically see what kind
of permissions are already in place and
you can then make changes you can
basically add members you can view by
different roles so for example here by
default it shows other services such as
data proc or your bucket owner or bucket
reader related permissions which have
been already granted now once I've have
looked at my bucket I can start using it
I can drag and drop and push in files
here so as of now there are no live
objects in my
object storage that is in my bucket what
I can do is I can click on upload files
and then I can choose a location from my
machine for example I'll go into data
sets and what I can do is I can choose
some of the files here in any format
let's choose CSV or text and just do
open so this one will basically upload
my data sets here now once I've uploaded
the files I can basically close this one
I can look into options here which says
edit permissions edit metadata if you
would want to download it if you would
want to copy move or rename it if you
would want to export to a different
service called Cloud Pub sub which is
publish subscribing messaging system you
can scan the data now you can click on a
particular file and that basically shows
you the URL which basically allows you
to access this file you can try copying
this you can click on download and
download this file you can even try
accessing this from public and that
basically shows you the content of this
file based on the permissions so this is
basically your object storage which is
one of the service which is offered what
you can also do is you can create
folders and within folders you can then
upload your data so this is your Google
Cloud Storage option which is for your
object storage that is you can add
different items you can give different
permissions and you can use this Google
Cloud platforms storage service offering
now you also have other options such as
big table and we can go into that by
clicking here and click on big table so
big table is one of the service which
kickstarted nosql databases today in
Market we see different nosql databases
such as cendra hbas mongod DB couch DB
Neo 4J and many others so you can
basically use big table which was the
Pioneer when it comes to your no SQL
databases or not only SQL databases so
the problem initially faced by Google
was that uh the web indexes behind
search engine were taking too long to
build so company wanted to build
database that would provide realtime
access to PAB of data and that's where
big table began so big table powers
different other Google services such as
Gmail Google Maps and other services and
in 2015 it was launched as a service for
customers so when it comes to
scalability with use of big table you
can increase your machine count without
any downtime and you can handle admin
tasks like upgrades restarts and so on
which are basically taken care Care by
the cloud provider data present in Cloud
big table is encrypted and you can use
IM roles to specify access so data
written to or from big table is through
data service layers such as managed
virtual machines hbas rest servers Java
Services hbas client and so on here if I
would want to use big table I can click
on create instance and that basically
tells me Cloud big table instance is a
container for your clusters now here you
can give a instance name so for example
I will say a UA and then say for example
test and let's say big table so that
will be the name of instance this will
be permanent you can choose the storage
type again you can go for lower latency
more rows red per second typically used
for realtime serving use cases or you
can go for sdds which have higher
latency for for random reads good
performance on scans and typically used
for batch analytics so let's go for ssds
as of now here you have cluster ID which
is autop populated you can choose a
region so let's go for our favorite one
here where I can say Europe West 3 I can
choose a Zone here and I can then choose
how many nodes would I want to use for
my big table so when you talk about big
table service it will have a cluster
underl which will have various nodes
which will control your data throughput
storage and rows read per second so as
of now let it be just one node and
that's enough for our demo when we talk
about performance it basically tells you
based on the current node and storage
type it tells you how many reads can
happen at millisecond so it says 10,000
rows per second at 6 millisecond you
have rights which are 10,000 rows per
second or you have scans which are 2 20
megab per second storage which is taken
care here would be 2.5 tabt and I can
then basically click on create now there
is also some option called replication
guidance which basically says
replication for cloud table big table
copies your data across multiple regions
enabling you to isolate workload and
increase the availability and durability
of your data depending on your use case
you can have big table which can be used
to have your data across regions now you
can click on create with all your
specifications Chosen and that's going
to set up a cluster or you can say a
fully managed nosql database which will
give you low latency and replication for
high availability now once we have a new
instance you can connect to it with the
CBT command line tool and for
instructions you can click on learn more
here you can just click on this instance
ID to see the details again if you would
want to look into your big table setup
so it tells me here that we have one
instance what is the CPU utilization
time how many rows were read or written
what is the throughput and this is autop
populated based on your usage you can
click on monitoring and that basically
will give you different widgets which
will display information for your CPU
utilization what is your hottest node
depending on how many nodes you have
system errors automatic failovers
storage utilization and so on you can
click on key visualizer which will allow
you to look into your table if you have
already created some data here and you
can click on tables to see how many
tables you have added here so that's in
brief about your big tables which is one
thing which we need to remember is it's
not good for all use cases so should be
used for low latency access that is fast
access and good if at least data is
greater than 1 tbte for smaller amount
of data the overhead is too high so big
tables performance will suffer if you
store individual elements larger than 10
megabytes if you want to store bigger
objects such as images video files then
go for object storage and that would be
a better option so always remember big
table is not a relational database it's
a nosql database and when you talk about
multi transactions or online transaction
processing big table is not the right
choice so it can be used for wide range
of applications especially when you talk
about your olab that is online
analytical processing so it is designed
to store key value Pairs and there can
be different use cases so for example if
you're using something like cloud data
flow or cloud data proc where you would
want map reduce kind of operations big
table can act as a good storage because
it has very high throughput and
scalability and the best thing is that
it supports hbas API thus allowing easy
integration with Apache Hadoop and Spar
clusters which you can bring up using
one more service which Google Cloud
platform offers which is called cloud
data proc so big table is good for
real-time analytics it's commonly seen
in financial services iot and others and
if you are thinking of running
interactive SQL then big table would not
be the right choice but the other choice
would be big query you should also
remember that this has a cluster running
and you would be charged if this cluster
kept on running so you have to be very
careful in your free account when you're
using such Services now we have clicked
on this one so I can select this one and
basically I can look at the permissions
I can look at the labels I can look at
inherited permissions here I can also
click on my instance which we created
and either you can edit or you can just
do a delete so as of now we will just
delete this which needs you to give the
name so we'll say AUA test BT and then
click on delete so whenever you are
trying out different Services the first
approach should be setting up these
different Services seeing how they work
basically trying connecting to them and
once you are satisfied with the initial
test then you can plan your actions and
come back and use the service for a
longer duration now that's your big
table which is one of the offerings we
can go back into storage and here you
have other options which are available
so for example we were in big table you
also have an option such as cloud data
store now that's one more service which
is offered by Google Cloud platform when
when it comes to storage domain so
Google added software on top of big
table which supports more than simple
key value pairs when you talk about
secondary indexes instead of just having
one primary index when you talk about
asset properties for Reliable
transactions such as SQL query like
language so these features or these
Services were added to or on top of your
big table which gave birth to a new
service which was released as cloud data
store so this is where you have cloud
data store and you can select a CL Cloud
fire store mode so you can go for a
native mode enable all Cloud fire stores
features with offline support or you can
go for Cloud's data store system on top
of Cloud's fire store so these are
different options here and here we look
at the API or scalability engine support
how many rights it supports and so on
you can choose one of these and and then
you can choose where to store your data
so for example if I click on this one
then it choose asks me to choose a
location so it says the location of your
database effect its cost availability
and durability choose a regional
location lower right latency lower cost
or multi- region location here I can
basically choose for example Europe and
then I can go ahead and create a
database so it says initializing Cloud
fire store in data store mode ser
services in eu3 this usually takes a few
minutes you'll be redirect to your
database once it is ready so if we
compare the pricing structure between
cloud data store and Cloud big table
always remember cloud data store you pay
for monthly storage which is also in the
case of big table however here you are
paying for monthly storage for reads and
rights but in case of big table you're
paying for cluster when it is running so
cloud data store is a good option for
small data infrequent access and it acts
cheaper when you talk about large amount
of data or big data and frequent access
then you are talking about Cloud big
table so big table is cheaper when you
talk about larger amount of data so here
it says since your database is empty you
can still switch to Cloud fire store in
Native mode to get more features you
could do that you could learn you could
say query by gql as of now we don't have
any data here let's look at the
dashboard which says since your database
is empty you can still switch to
cloudfire store in Native mode to get
more features so this is your cloud data
store and it has many features which
help you to work with your data however
some features or important features of
rdbms's were still missing and that's
where Google created yet another big
table base a service called Cloud
spanner now we can continue working on
cloud data store which basically gives
you one option to work with your data
you can create an entity here by
clicking on create entity and that
basically gives you options such as
default name space you can give a kind
you can give numeric ID and you can
start adding properties but to learn
more about data store we will learn
about this in further sessions so as of
now I'm going to click on cancel I'm
going to go back to my data store and
this basically let's go to data store
option or I can go into admin here which
basically says if you have entities you
can import or export them so let's go
back and let's again look into storage
options so as of now we were in data
store let's click on this one so as I
mentioned your cloud data store which
basically gives you some additional
features on top of your big table but
what Google also did was it realized
that there was a need for rdbms feature
support that is there were lot of
features now here we have created a data
store and it says your datab base is
ready to go just add data you can create
entity start putting in data and then
you can go ahead and query this so if
you would want to learn more about your
data store you can just click on this
one and that takes you to the complete
documentation of native mode and data
store mode what is fire store in Native
mode what is in data store mode what are
pricing and locations how you choose a
database mode what are the feature
comparisons what you can do what you are
allowed to do here what programming
languages can be used different regions
pricing and so on as of now we'll click
on this one and let's look at one
Advanced service which Google Cloud came
up with when it comes to your additional
features of rdbms so Google created yet
another big table based service called
Cloud spanner now that you might not see
here but if you scroll down you should
be able to see your Cloud spanner in the
options here or did we miss it on the
top so let's again look here yeah so it
is here and you can click on spanner so
Cloud spanner was released in 2017 it
basically supports relational schema so
it offers strong consistency for all
queries which can be SQL based you can
have multi- region deployment now when
it comes to massive scalability
requirement and strong consistency Cloud
spanner is a good option so it says
Cloud spanner is a managed Mission
critical globally consistent and
scalable relational database so if you
would want to use this then you will
have to enable this API where shows you
an option here it says try this API so
so it's a managed service so it is one
of the Google's most expensive database
Services there is also one more database
service which is cloudsql which can be
used so when we talk about your Cloud
spanner it is fully managed relational
database service it is massively
distributed you can have millions of
machines across hundreds of data centers
with support automatic sharding and
synchronous replication it gives you low
latency and schema updates without Dum
time making data High availability and
reliability so we'll learn about Cloud
spanner with more details later in other
sessions now we can also go back to
storage and we can look at the different
options which we have here so you have
object storage you have spanner you also
have your SQL based service which is yet
another manage service offered by cloud
or Google Cloud I would say so that's
called cloudsql so this is basically a
service which allows you to have fully
managed relational MySQL postgress and
SQL Server databases Google handles
replication patch management database
management and other things which are
related to this managed or fully managed
database service it can allow you to
handle terabytes of storage capacity
with
40,000 iops with huge amount of Ram per
instance so you can click on create
instance here and then you can choose
one of the database which you would want
to use so cloudsql is a managed service
you can choose one of your MySQL or post
and SQL Server say for example I choose
MySQL now that basically tells me what
is the instance ID it sets up a password
you can always change the password you
can change the region you can choose
your database version
and then you can also look at other
configuration options which talk about
machine type which will be used what is
about your backup and Recovery
maintenance and all that and if you
click on create this will basically
create a fully managed SQL service which
can allow you to straight away start
using MySQL on cloud thus allowing you
to store your relational data when we
talk about storage options how can we
not talk about a data solution or
basically an option which allows you to
run your queries by directly updating
data so you can use a data warehouse
service which Google Cloud platform
offers and that's called big query so
basically you can be looking into the
Big Data section here and here you have
an option called Big query so this
basically brings ease of implementation
and speed so building your own data
Weare house can be expensive time
consuming and difficult to scale so with
big query you just load data and pay
only for what you use so it when it
comes to Features you have features such
as capability to process billions of
rows in seconds and if you would want to
do realtime analysis of streaming data
that is also possible here so here we
have clicked on big query which
basically shows you the option where you
can start typing your query and test
your data access for example example if
I have uploaded some data so it shows me
there are some queries which are saved
here now I can schedule your query I can
basically choose the format of a
particular query by clicking on this
more here I have an option which says
add data so I can pin it to a particular
project I can explore public data sets I
can create a connection so if I click on
explore public data sets then it takes
me to a page from where you can get
different kind kind of data sets which
are already available which you can put
into your big query and start querying
your data by default it shows that it is
aligned to my project and I don't need
to worry about it I can look at saved
queries if I have already saved a
particular query I can look at job
history I can look at transfers
scheduled queries and reservations so
big query basically initially had its
own version of SQL which was slightly
different from standard SQL but in 2016
big query 2 was released that supports
SQL 2011 standard you can always select
standard SQL now big query when it comes
to pricing we need to remember that the
storage is the storage cost is very less
here approximately 02 cents per GB per
month it is almost similar to near line
where you can also have low cost that is
01 cents per gigabyte per month there is
no charge for reading data from Storage
when it comes to querying and that's
where the cost is incurred so 1 terabyte
per month is free and after that it
costs few cents per gigabyte so this is
mainly for high volume customers there
is a flat rate P pricing which can be
used so when you talk about querying you
can save your query results you can
create data set to store the results
now results are put in a temp table in
Cache and after you are done with that
you can delete data set and delete all
the data so when you talk about loading
data into big query you can get the data
from cloud storage Google Drive cloud
data store stack driver stack uh driver
other options you have Cloud big table
or other web interfaces so you can
download from URL such as CSV Json on AO
you can create data set create table and
create from Source by doing a file
upload so 10 megabyte or less files can
be uploaded using web interface as an
option you can also use command line and
then you can start working with your big
query so here you can also work with
streaming data by basically pushing in
streaming data into your big query which
allows you to add one record at a time
now you could use something like cloud
data flow which allows you to use a
particular pipeline about cloud data
flow we will learn later so you can
benefit from different features of big
query and does use Google's offering to
work on your structured data or I would
say data which suits well in data
warehouses now these are some of the
storage related Services which Google
Cloud offers although we will learn
about using big query and running or
uploading some data by creating add data
set here by say creating connection or
using a public data set so as of now I
have this you can also access the
command line to work with this but we
will learn in detail about big query in
later sessions now here you can scroll
down and you also have an option within
Big Data space and that is your data
proc so when you talk about data proc
this is again a manage service which
allows you to run spark or Hadoop jobs
so especially if you are interested in
Big Data workload so for big data
processing for machine learning you can
always use cloud data proc this uses
compute engine instances under the hood
but takes care of management of these
instances so it's a it's a layer on top
to spin-off clusters it's a manage
service it's cheaper pay when the jobs
are running only it's fast because it it
is integrated with other Google cloud
services you have open- Source
components pre-installed and data proc
is integrated with Yan to make cluster
management easier when you talk about
data proc you can click on create
cluster and that basically allows you to
set up your cluster by choosing a
particular region which you would want
to use for example I'll choose europ
West 4 here it tells what kind of
machines you would want to use and by
default it has populated as the machine
here which is 4 CPU and 15 GB now since
you might be using a free account let's
not go for the highend machine let's go
for N1 standard 2 and then you can
scroll down it says what is the primary
dis what is the dis type and this one
was for your master machine that is
machine which will have the master
processes running then you have your
worker node configuration which tells
this will be let's choose a lower end
machine and we can choose how many
worker nodes you would have so it says
minimum two you can choose the ssds and
their capacity it talks about Yan course
and Yan memory which will be allocated
and here we have then option of clicking
on create so once you click on create
this will basically spin up a cluster
wherein you can straight away start
submitting jobs to this you can
basically go ahead once your cluster is
ready you can go into the cluster you
can submit a job you can choose a type
which is spark or any other application
which you would want to run and then
basically you can use this fully managed
service which allows you to to run your
big data clusters you can obviously
control access via roles or Access
Control list and you can have access as
it is at project level or based on your
data proc cluster or even at your worker
notes so we'll learn about data proc in
later sessions so as of now you see here
the cluster is getting created it says
the cloud storage bucket which it is
using is this one now I can click on
this and open link in a new tab it still
takes me into console but now it is
showing me the bucket which is being
used by your data proc cluster this is
the bucket which is being used and it is
being used for un underlying metadata
which gets stored here so you look at
the cluster related folders you can
click in these folders and then it can
see what is the script output what it is
doing and so on now I can come back here
to my bucket which will basically show
me what kind of buckets have been
created so you see data Pro service
automatically created some buckets which
will be holding some data you also have
some other buckets which were created
based on other services which we used
the access control is fine grained in
all cases plus it also shows our bucket
so underlying it is using compute
instances it is basically using let's go
here and let's go to compute engine and
let's look into VM instances so data
proc which has spun up a cluster is also
using the VM instances which we see here
are running it is using the buckets and
it has made a cluster ready to use so
you can click on this cluster and that
shows me my cluster related details if
there are any jobs running what are VM
instances what kind of configurations it
has used and you can look at different
details here you can look at the logs
you can click on jobs and that will show
you if you have basically run a job on
this ready to use cluster so it says
there is this particular job which was
run which was a spark job you can click
on submit and this one tells you what is
the job ID what is the region you would
choose for example we will again choose
for example Europe West 4 it tells what
is the job type so you can run all these
type of jobs in this cluster such as
Hadoop spark P spark Hive Pig Presto you
can give your jar file so if you have
packaged your application as a jar you
can mention that here you can pass in
some arguments you can also say some
other jar files add some properties and
then click on submit which will run your
job on this ready to use cluster now
since we have tested it I can basically
go ahead and do a delete I don't want to
incur any cost on these manage services
which are running so there are lot more
information about using these Services
which Google Cloud platform offers and
we can continue learning about these
Services as we explore your Google Cloud
console or even your command line option
now we can come out of this one by
clicking on this menu and then we have
other options such as kubernetes you
have Cloud functions you have your
networking related services monitoring
related Services different kind of tools
what you have you have other big data
specific Services which you can learn
about and for each of these service
Google has a very good documentation
available for example when you talk
about published subscribe messaging
system it is a realtime manage service
which basically is a Pioneer which was
used and now you have a famous service
such as Kafka which is being used for
your publish subscribing or messaging
system kind of
requirements so to conclude about Google
Cloud platform Services you can always
go to cloud.google.com and look into the
document section now here you have list
of different featured products you also
have list of your different domains and
services which Google Cloud offers and
you can learn about all the different
Services which are offered by Google
Cloud here you can click on featured
products and that basically shows you
compute engine Cloud run cloud storage
you have cloudsql big query Vision AI
you can scroll down and look at your
artificial intelligence and machine
learning related Services platform and
accelerators API
management so Google Cloud platform
offers different services in mainly in
your compute storage and databases you
have networking related Services Big
Data specifics developer tools Cloud AI
identity and Security iot Management
tools API platform and so on so
basically learn about the gcp services
which Google Cloud platform offers and
in detail you can play around with
different Services which are offered by
creating a free account and as I
demonstrated you can use any one of
these Services quick start them
basically connect to them put in your
data or use a manage service to manage
your data and benefit from Google Cloud
platform thus having modernized
infrastructure for your different use
cases
asure first let's understand what is
Microsoft
Azure Microsoft Azure is a growing set
of cloud-based Computing Services
offered to
Corporation developers
government and anybody else who wants to
build an app or run a business on the
internet without having to install and
manage Hardware or server
software in recent years it has eclipsed
both windows and office in terms of
sales making it Microsoft fastest
growing business
sector the Azure platform is designed to
assist organizations in over coming
obstacles and achieving their objectives
it supports a wide range of Industries
including e-commerce finance and a
number of
organization and it is open-source
compatible this gives consumers the
freedom to use whatever tools and
Technologies they
want now coming to how aure Works
customers who subscribe to aszure get
access to all of the services available
through the Azure interface
these Services allow subscribers to
create cloud-based
resources such as virtual machines and
databases Asha comes with five different
customer support solutions for Microsoft
basic developer standard professional
direct and
Premier the scope and cost of these
customer assistance programs vary all
asure accounts get basic assistance for
free however Microsoft charges a premium
for the other Support options developer
support is $29 per month $100 per month
for standard assistance and $1,000 per
month for professional direct
suppot Microsoft does not provide
pricing information for Premier
support now that we have covered the
basics of Microsoft Azure let's dive
down and explore the services offered by
asure well there are multiple services
offered by Azure like machine learning
analytics containers compute databases
developer
tools Devo hybrid and multicloud
identity
integration Internet of Things
management media migration mobile
networking Security Storage web and
virtual
desktop but among these we will be
discussing only a few which are widely
used by organizations and
individuals around the world and we will
be vividly discussing these features in
depth and these services are compute
containers databases identity security
networking and
storage now let's start with the first
one that
is
compute
asure compute is a service that allows
you to run cloud-based applications on
demand this CPUs memory networking and
operating systems are among the
Computing resources IT supplies and the
resources are on demand and can be
accessed in minutes or even seconds you
only pay for what you use and for how
long you use it aure offers a variety of
computing solutions for development and
testing application deployment and data
center
expansion Linux Windows Server SQL
Server orle IBM and sap are all
supported by the servers the following
are some of the most well-known Services
Azure virtual machines virtual machine
skill sets Azure container instances
Azure app service and Azure functions
are also serverless
Computing now let's let's discuss each
of this one by
one first is aure virtual
machines virtual machines are
software-based computer
simulations a virtual processor memory
storage and networking resources are
among the resources
available virtual machines or VMS run on
operating system and allow you to
install and run software much like a
regular computer you can use and operate
the virtual machine as if you were
sitting in front of it by utilizing a
remote desktop
client as for virtual machines allow you
to construct and operate virtual
machines in the cloud infrastructure as
a service is provided through virtual
machines and they can be used in a
variety of ways virtual machines are an
excellent solution when you need
complete control over an operating
system and its surroundings all of the
software running on the VM can be
customized just as on a real
machine also when you're running custom
software or hosting Arrangements this
capability comes in
handy now coming on to the next one that
is virtual machine scale sets scale sets
are an Asher computer resource that may
be used to deploy and manage a group of
identical virtual
machines virtual machines scale sets are
meant to provide real Auto scale when
all VMS are set up the
same virtual machines do not need to be
pre-provisioned as a result developing
large scale services for big Computing
big data and containerized workloads is
easy more VM instances can be added as
demand growth VM instances can be
withdrawn when demand decreases the
procedure might be human automated or a
hybrid of the
two now moving on to the next one that
is azure container
instances container instances are Azure
compute resources for managing and
deploying containers containers are
virtualized application environments
that are lightweight they're buil to be
dynamically formed scaled and stopped on
a single host machine you can run many
instances of a containerized application
then comes Azure app
Services you can create deploy and scale
Enterprise grade web mobile and API apps
on any platform with Azure app
Services while employing a fully managed
platform to handle infrastructure
maintenance you can meet stringent
performance scalability security and
compliance requirements a platform as a
service solution is app
service
and following that we have asob
functions when you simply care about the
code that runs your service and not the
underlying platform or infrastructure
functions are great they're frequently
used when you need to respond to an
event typically via R request a timer or
a message from another Azure service and
the job can be accomplished rapidly in
seconds or
less now that we have completed all the
services offered by compute let's
proceed to the next one that is
containers containers are a type of
virtualization system you can run
several containers on a single physical
or virtual host in the same way that you
can run numerous virtual machines on a
single physical
host unlike virtual machines you don't
have control over containers operating
system containers are lightweight and
designed to be built scaled up out and
stop dynamically whereas virtual
machines appear to be instance of an
operating system that you can connect to
and
administer containers are built to help
you to react to changes on the go
containers allow you to swiftly resume
in the event of a crash of Hardware
failure Docker is one of the most
popular container engines and Azure
supports it containers offer these
particular service
container instances aure container
services and container
registry container instances are the
quickest and easiest method to operate a
container in the ashure without needing
to manage virtual machines or use any
extra Services it's a pass service that
lets you upload your containers and have
them run for
you moving on to the next one are Asha
container
services Asha container services or Asha
kubernetes Services allows users to
manage deploy and control operations of
kubernetes
container orchestration is a term used
to describe the process of automating
managing and interacting with a large
number of
containers as your kubernetes service is
a comprehensive container orchestration
service for distributed architecture
and high volumes of
containers and then comes container
registry a container registry is used to
ease container development by easing
storage and management of container
images now that we have covered
containers and the services offered
let's move on to the next Asher service
that is
databases as your database is is a fully
managed platform as a service database
engine that automates the majority of
database management tasks such as
updating patching backups and
monitoring Microsoft has released a
manage instance aimed at on premises
clients so if we have any SQL databases
on premises that we want to migrate to
Azure without any complex configuration
or
ambiguity we can use manage instances
the most prominent services and database
service are asure Cosmos DB asure SQL
database and aure postre
SQL now coming to the aure cosmos DB as
your Cosmos DB is a multimodel globally
distributed database
service you may increase throughput and
storage across any number of azure
locations around the world in an elastic
and independent manner
you can use any way of several common
apis to get single digigit millisecond
data access throughput latency
availability and consistency assurances
are all covered by ashure Cosmos DB
service level
agreements now Azure Cosmos DB enables
schema less data allowing you to create
extremely responsive and always on apps
that can handle constantly changing data
this functionality can be used to store
data that has been updated and
maintained by users all around the
world so next comes aszure SQL
database aure SQL database is a
relational database based on the
Microsoft SQL Server database engines
most recent stable
version SQL database is a fast
dependable well-managed and secure
database you may use it to create data
driven applications and websites in your
preferred programming language without
having to worry about
infrastructure so SQL databases pass
capabilities allows you to concentrate
on the domain specific database
Administration and optimization task
that are vital to your
business SQL database is a fully managed
service with high availability backups
and other typical maintenance features
built in Microsoft is in charge of SQL
well on operating system code changes
you don't have to worry about the
infrastructure coming to the next one
the Azure posty
SQL now Azure database posty
SQL is a cloud-based relational database
solution the server software is based on
the open- source posty SQL database
engines
Community when you use ashure database
for a post GQ your experience with tools
and knowledge comes in handy more
however it has various benefits like in
comparison to on premisis resources
there is built in high availability to
ensure that your apps are always online
no additional configuration replication
or cost as
necessary pricing is straightforward and
adaptable you can expect consistent
performance thanks to a pricing tire
that includes software patch automatic
backups monitoring and
security within seconds scale up or down
as needed to ensure that your service
adapts to usage you can draw computation
and storage independently as
needed automatic backups can be
customized and restored to a specific
point in time for up to 35 days and
Enterprise level security to safeguard
sensitive data in transit and at restk
this production includes data encryption
on disk as well as SSL encryption for
client server
communication now we have covered one
more crucial service offered by Azure
now let's move ahead and explore another
service that is security and
identity these two services are
integrated so we will be discussing them
together identity management in specific
is a process of authenticating first and
then authorizing using security
principles and it involves controlling
information about those principal
identities it provides these important
Services as your security Center Key
world and very important aspect of azure
service that is azure active
directory Azure security Center first
Azure security Center is a collect ction
of tools for monitoring and managing the
security of virtual machines and other
cloud computing resources in Microsoft
public
Cloud the aszure security Center is
accessed through the ashure management
interface by
administrators they may find a number of
security tools in the security Center to
help them prevent identify and respond
to possible security risk to the Azure
deployment to use the security Center
organizations must have an ashure
subscription next is ashure
keyal Asher keyal is a cloud service for
storing and accessing secrets in a
secure manner anything you want to
restrict access to such as API Keys
passwords certificates or cryptographic
Keys is a secret Vols a manage and
Hardware security module pools are two
types of containers supported by the key
service software as well as HSM backed
Keys Secrets and certificates can be
stored in WS only HSM back keys are
supported by manage HSM
pools coming to the next one is aure
active
directory aure active directory or
ashure ad is a cloud-based identity and
access management service from Microsoft
that allows your employees to sign in
and access resources such as Microsoft
365 the Azure portal and thousands of
other size apps internal resources such
as apps on your company's intranet and
network as well as any Cloud apps built
by a
company ASR ad is required for signin
and identity protection in Microsoft
online business such as Microsoft 365
and
Azure if you sign up up for any
Microsoft online businesses you'll be
given access to ashr ad which includes
all of the free
services now we covered one more ashure
service let's move on to the next
service which is
networking now Azure provides the
scalability performance High
availability and Enterprise grade
security you need to satisfy your most
extreme workloads requirements with more
than 1 lak 65,000 M of private fibers
across 60 plus regions and 170 Plus
network poops around the
world customers will have a consistent
low latency experience thanks to service
and integrate smoothly across on
premises multicloud and Edge
locations so when you use asure
networking Network as a service you can
concentrate on delivering your
application
logic next Network Watcher Express root
monitor asure monitor or
vnet terminal access point are all as
your networking services that can be
used to monitor your network
resources so the first one we will talk
about our virtual
Network asual virtual networks allow
Azure services such as virtual machines
web apps and databases to connect with
one another with internet users and with
on premises client computers and asure
network is a collection of resources
that connects other Asher resources
isolation and
segmentation internet
communications communicate among asual
resources communicating with on promises
resources route Network traffic filter
Network traffic and connect virtual
networks are some of the code networking
features provided by Asha virtual
networks next we will talk about VPN
Gateway a virtual Network Gateway or VPN
Gateway is a form of the virtual Network
Gateway
asure instances are installed and aure
virtual Network instances and provide
connectivity for services such as a
sight tosite connection connects on
devices data centers to Virtual networks
a point to site link connects individual
devices to Virtual networks and a
network to network connection connects
virtual networks to other virtual
networks so now moving on in Express
root with the support of a connectivity
provider Express root allows you to
expand your on promises networks into
the Microsoft cloud over a private
connection
you can connect to Microsoft cloud
services such as Microsoft Azure and
Microsoft 365 using Express rout and any
to any ipvpn network a point topoint
ethernet Network or a virtual cross
connection through a connectivity
provider at a collocation facility can
all be used for
connectivity so express route
connections are not made through a
public network as as a result Express
rout connections provide more
reliability quicker speeds constant
latencies and higher security than
traditional internet
connections now we have reached the last
service offered by Azure that we will
discuss
storage Microsoft Azure storage platform
is a cloud storage technology designed
for current data storage
scenarios a massive scalable object
stored for data object disk storage for
aser virtual machines a file system
service for the cloud a messaging store
for Reliable Communications and a nosql
store at are all available through core
storage
Services the services offered by are
Azure blob storage Azure table storage
as your Q storage and as your file
storage so the first first one is azure
blob
storage blob storage is a Microsoft
Azure service for storing binary big
objects made up of unstructured material
like text photos and videos as well as
Associated
metadata blob storage objects can be
accessed through HTTP or https from
anywhere in the globe by users or
clients
applications blob storage objects can be
accessed using the Azure storage
rest API Azure power cell and Azure CLI
or a client library for Azure
storage coming to the next one is azure
table
storage large volumes of structured data
are stored in Azure table storage the
service is a nosql data store that takes
request from both inside and outside the
Azure
Cloud now Azure tables are great for
storing non-relational structured data
table storage can be used to store and
query large amount of structured non-
relational data and it will scale as
demand
grows moving on to the next one that is
as your Q
storage ashure Q storage is a service
that allows you to store massive amounts
of data authenticated HTTP or https call
allow you access the messages from
anywhere in the world a a q message can
have a maximum size of 64 KB a q can
hold millions of messages after the
storage of account's overall capacity
limit cues are widely used to build a
backlog of work for asynchronous
processing now coming to the last one is
azure file
storage Azure files provides fully
managed cloud files that can be accessed
VI the industry standard server message
blog or network file system
protocols cloud and on premisis
deployments can both Mount as your files
file shares at the same time Windows
Linux and Mac OS clients can access SMB
Azure file shares clients running Linux
or Mac OS can access NFS Azure file
shares additionally using aure file
synchronization SM SMB Azure file shares
can be C aade on Windows servers for
Rapid access near where the data is
used so now that we have covered all of
the important services offered by aure
and their F
functionality let's dive deeper into the
into the concept and look into how Azure
is better than other Cloud
platforms so first is Microsoft Azure
PASS gives developers the environment
tools and building blocks they need to
create and deploy new cloud services
quickly it also provides the critical
devops linkages required for monitoring
maintaining and fine-tuning such apps
Microsoft handles much of the
infrastructure management behind the
scenes with Azure pass as a result Azure
deployment allows for a singular
emphasis on
Innovations second is the compatibility
of Aer with the one of the most
beneficial feature of
asure and that is the net programming
language which gives Microsoft a
significant advantage over AWS and the
rest of the competition Azure was
designed and tuned to work seamlessly
with both old and new apps built on the
platform framework for net
programming now Azure was built using
the security development citec which is
a leading Assurance process in the
industry it has security at its core
ensuring that private data and services
are kept secure and protected while on
Azure
Cloud fourth is on ASO hybrid apps like
can be created that take advantage of
resources in data centers at the service
providers in or within aure itself to
increase usability and speed a a now
offers a greater selection of hybrid
connections such as virtual private
networks caches content delivery
networks and express rout
connections fifth is if a company
already utilizes Microsoft software it
is likely to be covered by Microsoft
Enterprise
agreement it is eligible to discounts on
Microsoft software because Microsoft
frequently modifies this a agreements to
reduce Azure pricing as a result of the
Enterprise agreement businesses can
often get large discounts for adopting
Azure let's have a quick demo for Azure
services for their better
understanding so in this demo we will
first create our Resource Group and an
SQL database for it and a server
also so first you need to log in in your
Microsoft asure account
and then click here and go to Resource
groups click on create
button so for subscription we will have
our free trial
option and uh give it a name according
to our requirement like for now I'm
giving it uh as
your
demo
simply and then Vision according to your
uh area like where you want to deploy
your apps where you that you will be
publishing here and click on review plus
create here you will get all the
information that you need to review that
all the information here are correct or
not and then click on create
button it will take a few
seconds now you can see see this
notification that your resource Group is
created and here you can see that uh
your the name of your resource Group the
subscription and the
location so now what we need to do is we
will create a SQL database for it here
you can see all the
details so to create our SQL database uh
we will first just need to create a web
app so where we need to go
is we will go to app
services and here we will click on
create
button and again we need to give it a a
first we need to select our Resource
Group so we will click on the resource
Group we just created
and we will uh give it a
name so here uh I'm giving it as
your
demo simply web app and click on code so
that uh while publishing we can upload
our
code and runtime stack we can uh select
the language we have
created our application
in again the
reion and click on review plus create so
here you can just review all the details
you just
uh
mentioned it's taking a
while yeah so here you can see
subscription Resource Group which you
just created name you gave and uh the
publishing
runtime
stack now all you need to do is click on
create you can see it's initializing
deployment uh you need to be very
careful with the region because
sometimes it may create problem while
deploying
you can see deployment is in
progress now you can see your deployment
is
completed
so we just need to go to
resources
coming back to the page you can see uh
the name of your application you just
created now as we are done with the web
app uh now we need to create our uh SQL
database so coming to the SQL database
page we will click on create
button again the subscription we have to
give free trial and the resource Group
we just created because that's what
where we are publishing our web
application and that's where we need to
create uh attach our database
with so now we need to give a name to
our database so here I'm
giving
so I'm giving it as your demo SQL
DB and uh here you can see that we don't
have any items to select as a server so
we will click on create
new here we will create a server for our
SQL database and uh give it a
name
so I'm giving it a
name this
is
sorry I'm giving it a name as your
simply
server as you can see it's already taken
so I need to change it so let's take as
your demo
server yeah so now we are done with the
name again for location we need to
mention the region so here you can see
I've have
selected now
coming here we have to enter our admin
login so here I'm giving my
organization's
name
I need to give it a
password then confirm
password and click on
okay
so here you can
see that database name has already been
attached to it the database we just
created for elastic pool we will go for
no option only and uh then again we will
click on review plus
create so here you can see all of the
information that you just
mentioned whatever privileges you will
have with your SQL database and click on
create you can see uh deployment has
been
initialized it's going to take a
while you can see the
status constantly and track them
here you can see deployment is in
progress and in a while you will see the
name being flashed over
here now you can see your deployment is
completed and in deployment details you
can see your database being created and
the demo server you just
created now going back to your resource
Group the one we created at first
clicking on the
name we can see all the task we just did
like creating a web app Cate creating a
database for it and also a server for
your
database now all you need to do is
publish your uh application that you
created for yourself and deploy it over
here let's look into what is AWS AWS is
a broadly adapted Cloud platform which
offers several ond demand operations
like compute power database storage
content delivery Etc and that helps
corporate scale and grow AWS Services
can be used to create and deploy any
application in the cloud for example it
provides services over the Internet just
like worldwide web and AWS is the
largest cloud platform available that
you can use for either creating the
application creating the databases
likewise the other features also you can
use simultaneously now what are the
benefits of
AWS the first is it is easy to use for
using the AWS you require the good
internet connectivity and then you can
actually browse it using the web console
and also you can use the command line
interfaces as well second flexibility
AWS offers you a flexibility so that you
can actually change or tweak your
Solutions whenever you require
reliability so with the help of the
Redundant infrastructure across the
globe the AWS gives you the reliability
that any application or any databases if
you're running on the AWS that would be
basically up all the time and there will
be no or very less downtime then comes
the scalability so scalability is one of
the important features of AWS and in
that case you can actually scale up your
resources at any time you require so for
example if any of your application is
over utilized and you require more
resources to run your application you
can do that on the Fly then comes cost
Effectiveness so AWS is a very cost
effective platform because here whatever
the service that you use that is charged
on a per hour usage only so you don't
have to pay the complete cost like you
do when you procure the infrastructure
in the data centers you don't have to uh
basically pay for the complete package
or usage of the service you just have to
pay for whatever time duration that you
have actually used that service and the
associated charges with it and that
makes the AWS a very cost- effective
solution then comes the security so a is
a secure platform and lot of measures
have been taken so that the security can
be enhanced and upgraded in the AWS so
from the infrastructure level the AWS
have a very high level of security that
is implemented and from the application
and the solution perspective it gives
you lot of features where you can
actually apply the security as per your
requirement onto your applications
coming to the AWS services so
essentially AWS services are compute
storage database migration networking
and content delivery developer tools
management tools Media Services machine
learning analytics security identity and
compliance mobile
services application integration arvr
which is augmented reality and virtual
reality customer engagement business
productivity desktop and app streaming
internet of things which as iot
now let's look into the compute service
which is one of the widely used service
on the AWS and what does the compute
service do these Services help
developers build deploy and scale an
application in the cloud platform that
is ec2 Lambda elastic container service
elastic load balancer light sale and
elastic bean stock these are the
services which lie in the compute
service section only one of the the most
widely used service within the compute
section is ec2 which stands for elastic
Cloud compute it is a web service that
allows developer to rent virtual
machines and help to resize the compute
capacity so here what you can do is you
can run the virtual machines and you
have the Privileges to select the type
of operating system that you want uh
should be running on your instances or
on your virtual machines and likewise
later you can customize as for your
requirement Lambda is a serverless
compute service it is also responsible
to execute code for a specific
application so those who are from the
development background they can focus
more on creation of a code they don't
have to create a server manage it
instead they can use a Lambda where you
they can deploy their code directly onto
the Lambda server then comes the storage
service now couple of storage services
are S3 glacia EBS which is elastic block
Storage storage Gateway now AWS provides
web data storage service for archiving
data also its main advantage is disaster
data recovery with high durability let's
look into some of the essential storage
services and one of the most widely used
storage Services S3 which stands for
simple storage service in the simple
storage service what you need to do is
you have to create a bucket and in that
bucket you have to put the files in it
so S3 gives open cloud-based storage
service which is utilized for online
data backup then comes the EBS which is
an elastic block storage now you can
understand EBS as a virtual hard drive
also which attaches with the ec2 and it
provides High availability storage
volume for persistent data it is mainly
used by Amazon ec2 instances then you
have the database Services AWS database
domain service offers cost efficient
highly secure and scalable database
instances in the cloud and some of the
database services are RDS which is a
relational database service Dynamo DB
the non- relational or no SQL or nosql
database service elastic and Amazon red
shift now one of the essential database
service is the Dynam DV it is a flexible
nosql database service which offers fast
and reliable performance with no
scalability issues it is fast reliable
highly scalable and suitable for small
scale applications like mobile
applications gaming applications or
anything with respect to the Internet of
Things devices there the Dynamo DB is uh
most widely used or suitable then comes
the the relational database service that
is the RDS which is a structure database
service it is a managed distributed
relational database cloud service that
helps developers to operate and scale
database in a simple manner so RDS has
different vendors platform with respect
to the database U usage and that
includes the post gr SQL MySQL then you
have Oracle Microsoft or mssql and uh
they have their own
customized database U as well that is
called as the Amazon Aurora along with
that they have a Maria database or Maria
DB as well so these are couple of
vendors that give their database engines
uh that you can use on the RDS now
coming to the networking Services it
offers a highly secure Cloud platform
and helps in connecting your physical
Network to your private virtual network
with high transfer
speed now some of the services in the
networking and content delivery are VPC
which is a virtual private Cloud a very
important service in order to make your
applications or uh Services more secure
roote 53 which is a DNS mapping Service
Direct Connect which directly connects
with the AWS services and with your data
centers and the cloud front that is
basically a Content delivery service now
coming to the VPC or a virtual private
Cloud it helps a developer to deploy AWS
resources such as Amazon ec2 instances
in a private virtual Cloud so that you
can actually make your ec2 isolated or
make it more secure and even you can
make it for a public access also depends
on the administrator that how they want
to customize it so the complete control
of a VPC and its networking is with the
admins then comes the root 53 service it
is a web service with highly available
domain name system or the DNS that helps
user to Route software by translating
text into IP address and that is why it
is called as a DNS mapping service and
that helps you to use your domains or
the external domains pointed to the AWS
services in case if you use AWS for
hosting your website sites or the
applications note DNS translates text
into the IP address now coming to the
developer tool services it helps a user
build deploy and run an application
source code automatically it also
updates a server and instance on the
workload so first is the code star code
build code deploy code pipeline so codar
it is a service designed to manage
application development at a single
place here developers can quickly
develop build and deploy applications on
AWS so all the manage app development
can be done with the Cod star code build
removes the hassle of managing physical
servers and helps developer build and
test code with continuous scaling so
security identity and compliance
Services helps in monitoring a safe
environment for your AWS Resources by
providing limited access to specific
users so in case let's assume that you
have to give an access to someone but
with limited privileges you can
primarily use IM am in that case and if
you want to make your applications or um
deployments more secure then you can use
uh these services like uh KMS IM Cognito
uh WF which acts as a firewall now the
IM service which is the identity access
management is a framework that helps in
maintaining access to AWS services in a
secure way so what happens is that the
admin who has the complete access of the
AWS console provide access to users and
there can be different users and they
would have the privilege accesses uh
defined by the Admin so what type of
permissions the admin gives them uh they
would have those limited access on the
AWS console KMS enables users to create
and manage the encryption keys that are
used for encrypting data coming to
management tool services with the help
of management tools using the service an
individual can optimize cost minimize
risk and automate all the resources
running on the AWS infrastructure
efficiently so with the management tools
you can monitor the resources
application its uh its tools and the
utilizations and along with that you can
scale up scale down the resources
likewise with the help of the management
tools you can also do the auditing task
so one of the essential service in the
management tool services the cloud watch
it is a monitoring tool for AWS
resources and customer applications
running on AWS platform so let's assume
that you have used ec2 Dynam DB S3 RDS
and you want to monitor those resources
you can use the cloud watch that can
give you the results coming to the cloud
formation this service helps you in
monitoring all your AWS resources at one
place so that you can spend minimum time
in managing those resources and maximum
time on developing the application so
with the help of the cloud formation you
can deploy the entire solution with the
help of creation of a template you just
need to create one template and you have
to deploy it the rest of the things will
be done by the a players and hence it is
a kind of an automation task only now
let's look into the demo of some of the
essential
services so we'll start with the ec2 and
I have already logged in into my AWS
account so where exactly you can find
the ec2 just click on the
services under the compute section you
can find the ec2 ec2 stands for elastic
Cloud compute service primarily used for
creating the virtual machines so I'll
click on the service and quickly I'll
show you how the virtual machine is
created and how we can basically access
it so I would be creating one virtual
machine or an instance with the Windows
operating system so here you can see
there are three instances which are
already running let me create another
one you have to click on launch
instances and here you have to select
some configuration details so most of
the configuration details I'll be taking
as default and wherever it is necessary
I'll be making the
changes so first of all you have to
select the operating system in the form
of Ami and I would be looking for
Windows uh 2016 and then you have to
select the type of instance with respect
to the CPUs number of CPUs and the
memory capacity so I'll go with t2.
micro which is a pre tier eligible
instance in the configure instance
details the rest of the things we'll
keep it as default as of now click on
add storage this is a basically the
virtual hard drive or the EBS the
elastic block storage that is attached
with the ec2 instance so primarily it is
giving us 30 GB of space without any
additional cost we can leave the tags as
blank click on configure security groups
and here you can see that the RDP Port
is by default open which will actually
allow us to RDP or to have a remote
connectivity of our
instance click on review and launch now
to give an authentication or to provide
an authentication we should have a key
pair with us so that the AWS
can understand or can tally the key pair
and give us the access so I already have
a key pair created what I'll do is I'll
create a new key pair for this instance
and put a random name let's say I put it
something like demo download the key
pair and make sure that you keep your
key pair in a safe and secure place
click on launch instances
now you will see that there is an
instance ID that has been created which
is a number alpha numeric number that is
randomly given by the
AWS you can name your
instances so let's assume let's say we
name our instance as Windows
2016 click on Save
and the AWS deploys our instance on a
respective infrastructure it gives us
the IP addresses the public IP and the
private IP which is an internal IP and
we have to access the instance from the
public IP only so now to access that
instance we have to open up the
RDP put the public IP click on
connect and when it asks you for the
authentications you put a username as
administrator and the password you have
to generate by providing the keep so
click on
connect and then uh you have to click on
RDP client here you have to get a
password so click on get
password browse and when you click on
browse you have to provide demo. PM file
so it should be in the download section
here
itself just provide that key pair and it
is going to give you the password in the
encrypted format decrypt your
password copy that and then provide
those
details to the RDP client click on okay
and now it should allow you to log to
the instance let's wait for the windows
to appear so here you can see
that we have uh logged in into the
windows instance the windows 2016 screen
is available in front of us if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more in
this particular demonstration I would be
explaining you about how to use a
storage service specifically the S3
service which is most widely used
service under the storage section now
the S3 stands for simple storage service
primarily used for storing the objects
and the files and uh what we need to do
is we just have to click on the S3
service under the storage
section so when you click on S3 service
um you have to create the buckets inside
the
S3 and the buckets are the places where
you keep your folders or you upload the
files that are available on your
systems so here if you'll notice notice
that the S3 service is a global Service
that means it is irrespective of the
region and uh the buckets when you
create they are created in a specific
region now what is the
benefit the benefit is that if you
create a bucket in different regions all
those buckets in different regions can
be viewed from a single
dashboard and uh you don't have to
change the region again and again to
view the S3 buckets so what you need to
do is you have to click on create bucket
and here you have to specify the name of
the bucket so let's say I put something
like demo
AWS and
uh that's the bucket name I going to
select now make sure that the bucket
name starts with the lowercase and it
should be always unique now why it
should be unique because since S3 is a
global Service so it may be that
somebody else could be using
your the name that you have provided so
it should be always unique otherwise it
will not be
allocated now you have to select a
region and that would be let's say I go
with the Ohio
region and uh in the bucket settings you
can basically change and configure these
settings according to your requirement
by default uh when you create a
bucket it blocks all the public access
from the bucket so when you have all
public access
blocked no object can be viewed from the
S3 Bucket from a public network or from
or by anyone
else and hence uh in order to view the
objects or the or the files in the
bucket you have to unblock or uncheck
this option so that first of all you
make the bucket accessible from the
public network likewise you can
customize as per the requirement and
then click on acknowledgement the rest
of the things we keep it as default
and click on create bucket now it says
that the bucket with the same name
already exists so that means it is not a
unique name somebody else might have
been using this name so I'll try to keep
it more unique and I'll try to assign
some number so let's say I put something
like
987 and it says it is already existed
let's say
9876 and then click on create bucket now
if it creates a bucket that means we
have been allocated with that bucket
name so let's let's wait for wait for a
minute to get that bucket
created so that happens quickly and you
can see there are couple of buckets
already created here and these buckets
can be viewed in a single dashboard so
some of the buckets are in Mumbai region
some of the buckets are in Ohio region
but they are available in the same or a
single dashboard so I'll open up the
bucket that I have recently created and
I'll try to upload some documents now
what you can do is you can you can
create a folder also inside the S3 and
when you create a folder you can upload
the objects accordingly otherwise you
can directly also upload the objects so
click on upload and we will upload any
random file from my system onto the
S so I'll uh basically
file and then click on
upload now it is uploading my object
from my system onto uh the S3
bucket and now it has successfully done
so it says the message is successful now
in order to validate I will click on the
bucket from the S3 service and view this
object now you can see here is my bucket
so I'll just open up this bucket and uh
these DNS records. CSV file is available
with us now the S3 is not only limited
till storing the objects or the files it
has many other functionalities and the
features also like you can enable
versioning you can host a static website
on the
S3 along with that uh you can have a
cross region replication enabled so that
you can have a high availability of your
objects or you can have a redundancy of
your critical objects in different
regions so likewise there are more
features um that would be covered up in
the detail section of an S3 service now
coming to another section of the
essential services that is the
database now here you can see I have a
database section in the AWS and it has
multiple service within
in uh the RDS is there Dynamo DB is
there elastication and the other
database services are there uh so I
would be showing a demo on the Dynamo DB
which is a nosql
database now
when we say it is a nosql database that
means it is a non-relational database
service where we can create a database
table directly from the web console we
don't require a separate database engine
uh like uh in the case of
RDS and uh in the tables you can insert
the values and view those values
directly from the AWS dashboard
itself so it says Amazon Dynamo DB is a
fast and flexible no SQL database
service primarily suitable for and web
gaming and other mobile applications so
what you need to do is it is a
straightforward uh database service
which is which can be accessed while
creating a table itself and it's a
compute based database service that is
the reason that it is more fast so click
on create
table and what you need to do is you
just have to put a table name so I'll
just put something like
test
and uh in the partition keys so these
partition keys are unique entities so
what you need to do is you have to
specify a partition key so I'll put
something like
ID and the string instead of string I'll
use a
number likewise I can add sort Keys Also
let's say I put a
name and the name should be in the
string format now these are the unique
entries these are the fixed entries in
the table and after that we are going to
put the attributes and in the attributes
the data will be inserted so what you
need to do is rest of the things we'll
keep it as default as of now click on
Create
and here you can see the table has been
created the test table has been created
now if I click on the items so you would
see that it has the sort Keys available
the ID and the s key associated with
that that is the name but it does not
have any entry because we have not added
any value or the attributes so how we
can add or insert the values in this
table that can be done many ways you can
enter manually you can use the help of
CLI to enter the large chunk of data
directly uh upload it onto the Dynamo DB
table and also you can use the apis also
in order to insert the data inside the
table so what you will do is we will
click on create
item and in the ID we will put some
value let's say number one string uh
let's say we put something
like uh we will go with a random name so
instead of putting any name we'll put a
value like AB a BCD that should be fine
and
then we will insert some attributes so
let's say I put string as Rank and I'll
put something like like rank
two and then click on save so here you
will see just refresh the database
table close it and open it up
again click on the
items now here you can see the ID one
name is ABCD got the rank two likewise
you can click on create items let's say
the serial number or the ID 2 name let's
say we put something like uh we can go
with XY Z any random thing put it up as
number rank and let's say this
particular value got a rank
three likewise you can add some more
items string let's say you put something
like
ajk and you put a rank let's say it's a
rank number one one holder rank one
holder right so likewise uh this is just
an example likewise you can add the
attributes as per your need and U the
table can be filtered out based on the
attributes also so if you have to search
some values in the Dynamo DB table so
you can always use
filters uh to basically search the
values uh inside the table apart from
that the Dynamo TB table has lot of
other function alties um uh it can be
basically uh you can have a backup of a
table created in the Dynamo DB table in
the Dynamo database and then you can
retrieve or recover the data by
restoring the backups from the Dynamo DB
this database can be created in the
cluster format also so these are couple
of features uh that you can use with the
Dynamo
DB now let's move into to the next
section now coming to the networking
services so there are some of the
networking Services which are very
useful and uh that includes a VPC which
is a virtual private Cloud cloudfront
Route 53 API Gateway
Etc now I will uh basically demonstrate
about the root 53 Service uh in this
demo so in the root 53 is basically a
DNS mapping service so what you can do
is let's assume that you are hosting any
web application on the server and you
want to Route the domain traffic onto
those servers you need to have the help
of root 53 to do that so what you need
to do is you just have to click on roote
53 service and from this service you can
register your domains also otherwise if
you have domains purchased from any
external site you can point them to the
root 53 name servers also so first of
all in the roote 53 you have to create a
hosted zone so there is already one
hosted Zone all created now when you
create a hosted Zone you have to specify
the domain name so let me show you I
have one dumy
domain this is the domain uh that has
been defined so what you have to do is
when you click on create hosted Zone you
have to put a domain here you can see
example.com likewise you have to put
your own
domain and uh click on the public hosted
Zone click on create hostage Zone and it
is going to give you four name server
now those four name servers have to be
updated on the platform from where you
have purchased the domain so that is
mandatory in order to Route the traffic
to the Route 53
service right so here you can see I
already have a hosted Zone created for a
domain and it has given
me four name servers these are the name
servers and these name servers have been
updated in a record set from where the
domain has been purchased right once it
is done then you have to Route the
domain traffic to a server so what you
have to do is you have to click on
create
record and in the create record you have
to specify the IP address or you can use
the alas also where the traffic should
be routed to where your application is
hosted at so ideally it is a server
details
and it exists with certain policies also
so you can see some view existing
records so here you can
see this particular domain is routed to
a DNS value which is hosted in the
lastic bean stock instead of that you
can put an IP address of the ec2
instance also you can use the S3 URL
also you can use the cloudfront URL also
so likewise what will happen is that the
domain traffic will be routed to the
server where actually the application or
a web application is hosted at now I'm
using a routing policy as simple routing
policy that means all the traffic should
be routed to that particular domain
whereas there are other routing policies
also in the Route 53 that includes the
weighted routing policy which acts as a
kind of a load balancing geolocation
routing policy multivalue answer routing
policy and then you have a redundancy
based routing policy which is a failover
one so likewise you can select as per
your
requirement so what you need to do is
you just have to click on create records
uh you have to specify you have the
domain so you have to specify any uh
particular info you want to put before
the domain otherwise you can leave it as
blank and in the record type let's
assume that you are using an IP address
of a server where uh your web
application is hosted at so you can
basically use a routes traffic to an IP
V4 address and put an IP address address
make sure that you put a public IP
address or the elastic IP address
attached to your instance in case if
you're not using any particular IP
address or the URL you can use the Alias
also so likewise U the records can be
created along with that uh the Route 53
Services used for domain verifications
also like uh if you want uh the email
services on onto your web application
then you can basically verify your
domain directly from the roote 53
service you can uh get the verification
done for the SSL certificate creation
for that also the records will be
directly created from the Route 53
service because it is actually managing
or hosting your uh
domain now with respect to the security
services uh the most widely used service
is the IM am which is identity access
management that lies under security
identity and compliance so in from the
IM you can create the users uh whom you
want to give an access to to your AWS
console you can create groups and you
can add multiple users in that group
give them the permissions you can create
the rules also so that uh multiple
Services can interact or integrated
together so how the IM is used uh click
on the IM
service and I'll show you how a
particular user can be created and U how
the user is basically uses the
credentials to access the AWS console
now the IM dashboard is open and when
you open up the IM dashboard it gives
you the URL so this is the URL through
which uh the user has to actually access
the AWS console by providing the user
credentials now how the users are
created just click on the users and U
here you just have to click on add user
so I'll create one sample user let's say
I put something like sample
user and what type of an access you want
to give that particular user do you want
to give a programmatic access which is
primarily the CLI access or you want to
give the AWS Management console so right
now we'll go with the AWS Management
console access now do you want an
autogeneration of the password or do you
want to customize the password so let's
assume that we customize the password so
put any
value make sure the password meets all
the
criterias and uh then click on next
permissions now what kind of permissions
you want to give to that user let's
assume that you want to give an access
of a particular service only to that
user so you have to actually search you
have to actually search a policy for
that particular service um that can be
given an access to a user otherwise if
you want to give an admin policy or the
admin access to that user you can search
an admin policy there so the permissions
are important otherwise the user would
not have privileges to access um the AWS
console so we'll attach the existing
policies directly so click on it and
here let's assume that I want to give an
admin access to that user so I'll just
click on the admin access now to a
particular user you can give multiple
policies also it is not necessary that
you have to give only a single policy so
you can provide a multiple policies to
the users also now click on next tags
let let's make the tags blank click on
review and create a
user now you'll see that our sample user
would be created and to access the
console we'll just copy this URL which
has the account information as well that
is the account
number so copy the link or can copy the
complete URL log out from the root
account and
then past the URL that was copied from
the
console and then we have to give the
user
credentials so we'll put sample user as
the username and the password that we
provided while creating the
user click on sign in and if it is
correct then it should allow us to log
in into the AWS console while asking
the password
change so we'll change the password
confirm password
change and now it should allow us to
login into the root accounts AWS console
with the admin
privileges now the next service is the
monitoring services and under the
monitoring Services uh primarily the
cloud watch uh the cloud trail the cloud
formation and these are some of the
services that are most widely used now
the cloudwatch is a service which is
primarily used for monitoring the
metrics primarily of the servers like
for example if you create an ec2
instance and you want to uh basically
watch out for the metrics associated
with the CPU utilization or uh the
storage utilization the network in
network out all those information you
can get it from the cloudwatch now
cloudwatch is not
only related to monitoring the metrix it
can generate the alarms also and U here
you can get the events also generated
which or the events that can be created
which can trigger the Lambda function as
well so what you have to do is you just
have
to click on dashboard so iing metrics
are viewed uh with the help of the cloud
watch so first of all you have to create
a
dashboard now you have to put a
dashboard name let's say I put put
something like
monitoring
ec2 click on create dashboard now how do
you want the reports to be published you
have to actually select a widget I want
that okay the report should be visible
in the numeric form so I'll select a
number now click on the dashboard that
was created and uh
let's again add the
widget and here uh we'll select the
metric primarily for the E2 per instance
metric so we have one single instance
running now there are 14 metrics
available for that particular instance
now I would be looking for the CPU
utilization for this particular instance
so I'll just select for the CPU
utilization and it is going to give me
some information about what is the
current CPU utilization of that
particular instance so that is somewhere
around
29.3% uh the CP utilization has been
done for the single instance that is
running in my ec2 dashboard so likewise
you can add some more metrics and view
them in this particular dashboard and
the cloud watch will keep on publishing
the data uh at a refresh interval of 5
minutes that is uh the default value and
with that we have reached to the end of
this session on cloud services should
you need any assistance PPT or other
resources used in this session please
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts we'll be happy
to help you as soon as possible until
next time thank you and keep learning
stay tuned for more from Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here